the topic for today and there'll be all
sorts of topics throughout the week but
topic for today this morning at least is
number sense which is one of my favorite
topics to think about and really I
started thinking about it again I had
one of my former students who had taught
as a sixth grader who's now a junior no
senior who came and visited Hillsdale as
a prospective student and he was talking
to me about what the sixth graders and
now the seniors at my old school still
call the great Greg rampage of whatever
year it was big and apparently this is
now a thing like that that they bring up
but it happened when their sixth graders
and we were we were teaching the unit on
percents okay and I was just hammering
home this formula you know part equals
percent times whole right over and over
and over again part equals percent times
whole part equals percent times whole
and what gave him this test and there
were a couple word problems at the end
of this test and you know one was about
a 50 dollar bike on sale 20 percent off
what's the what's the final what's the
final price and I guarantee you I got I
got answers that were 75 dollars I got
answers that were two dollars and fifty
cents and I was just I was grading this
test and just furious and so I walked
into class the next day and I you know I
think I just let him I don't I don't
remember this but I must have just let
him have it and said when you definition
any problems you need to check your
answer and you better not see any of
these kind of answers that I don't this
is out I'm pretty straight myself doing
I don't I don't remember that happening
but it must have happened because they
call it the great Greg rampage and we
did you know we did an entire week of
every single time you got done with your
answer you went back and you checked it
and you made sure it made sense and you
had to write down on your homework
that's why this answer makes sense and
it's but okay so so you guys I'm sure
have had similar experiences right this
you know just stupid stuff like
a 200-mile trip that you take in four
hours that you do at 800 miles an hour
which it you just see these answers if
you want to just slam your head against
the whiteboard right you want to just
your your grading and you start drinking
and and from there it's not a pretty
sight the rest of the evening is not a
good mental or spiritual place for you
to be in as a person so not only is
number sense matter for your kids sake
it matters for your own sanity right
this is this is a but it all serious
right number sense is a very it's a it's
a tricky issue it's not something that
you're gonna solve by one week of making
your students check your answer their
answers it's not something that we're
gonna solve in 90 minutes here right
it's not something that you may even
solve over the course of your entire
teaching career but I don't think just
because we can't necessarily solve it
here that's not worth bringing to our
attention and it's not worth making some
progress right
I think there's it's it's worthwhile
even if you're going from a level one
number sense to me I don't know level
two or two-and-a-half right taking a kid
from there to there is worth it right
and it requires so what I'm hoping to do
is just bring up some bring up some
thoughts bring up some issues spark
maybe some discussion and spark a little
bit of you know for you to give it some
thought over the summer and go into the
fall and say I'm gonna be intentional
about this because number sense doesn't
happen what I'm here the main one of the
main points I want to say about number
sense is it's not something that either
kids have or don't have it's not
something that you're born with it's not
something natural okay certainly you're
going to encounter students that are
better at it than others
but number sense gets developed over the
course of time and over the course of
intentional teaching and there's ways
you can take
in whatever classroom you're in you're
in a fifth-grade math classroom you're
in a 12th grade math classroom you can
take intentional steps to make sure
number sense is a focal point of what
you're doing in the classroom so it's a
hundred percent not something that is on
it's not something that you just throw
up your hands and say well my kids just
don't have any number sense sure yeah
okay good so yeah let me yeah let's get
let's actually dig into this so what
what do we define how do we cuz cuz it's
a tricky thing to actually go and define
right you know it when you see it or you
don't see it right more often when you
don't see it right but what does it
consist of and this is probably one of
the harder things for me to sit down and
and write a definition of what number
sense is so what I want to do I want to
I want to actually try and take that
question and give it some give it some
form right allow us right that's a
really abstract question obviously I'm a
Singapore math person so like we
progress from the concrete to the
pictorial to the abstract right so so I
want to give it something formative
right and the best way I can think of to
do this is to give ourselves a math
problem right so I'm gonna give us a
couple math problems - math problems to
think about first everyone okay 2/3
minus 5/6 over 1/3 plus 2/9 all right
and to letter
the letter selected at random from each
of the following words Hillsdale College
what is the it's the probability that we
select one consonant and one vowel all
right and I'm gonna give you a few
seconds for you to do one or both of
these problems or for some of you
attempt one or both of these problems
but while you're doing it I want you to
think about a simple question I want you
to think about what makes me good at
solving this or if you're struggling
what are the roadblocks that I'm having
a hard time dealing with so that because
I think that's that's actually going to
give us a bit of an access in a number
sense right is we're all sitting here
mathematicians or amateur mathematicians
or whatever you want to call yourself
right but what is it that makes us good
at math or poor so take take a few
seconds solve one of these or I'll even
give some answers here or maybe I want
reality yeah let's see if someone can
come up with some of the answers but
solve wanted to solve one of these give
them a shot but ask yourself what is it
that makes me good at this problem what
that is it that allows me to get the
solution as opposed to not get the
solution
complex fractions in the summer you
gotta love it
you've got to love complex fractions in
the summer if y'all can remember here
trick to complex fractions I'd be really
helpful
it's not an easy one it's at least not a
I pulled that her from Hillsdale and I
pulled her from college all right I pull
a letter from Hillsdale and then I pull
a letter from college so a letter
selected from each of the following
words right pull Hillsdale pull one from
Hillsdale then pull on from college so
or or the other way around just the
probability like if I pull the S from
Hillsdale and the e from college that
would be good if I pull the H from
Hillsdale and the C from college that
would not satisfy
alright I'm gonna stop and we must stop
you guys there we could keep going but
hopefully you had a chance to think
about you know maybe maybe you didn't
tear your solution to the end but at
least think about what it is that makes
us good any willing to hazard an answer
for this one yes negative 3/10 is
correct
you have pretenses correct anyone
willing to hazard an answer for this one
10 that at 21 is correct yet 10 out of
20 1 is correct you guys can work the
rest of those out but what I'm really
looking for is what is it that allow
those of you got the right answers what
is it little that allowed you to get
those right answers those of you didn't
what is it that you struggled with what
were some of the roadblocks the head you
had to overcome thoughts does that makes
us good yeah ok so yeah maybe I'll keep
a list here all right
yeah knowledge of the concepts and the
and and you know you have to know
certain basic things what what a
fraction is what you should do first
right the fact that this line is
essentially a yeah divided by a kind of
thing yes
yeah factual fluency right some kind of
a if any of you were here for the some
of my lectures to kindergarten through
sixth grade teachers oh man I just beat
them over the head with the stick of
factual fluency than that being one of
the huge things you have to do in the
lower grades but yeah the fact that we
didn't have to stop and think what three
times two was or two times two if you
made yourself a common denominator up
there right the fact that we didn't
actually have to the fact that you know
so intimately that three times two is is
six that you don't even have to have to
think about what three times two is
right if I say eight plus seven how many
of you think fifteen no none of you
think fifteen you just associate eight
plus seven is so intimately tied with
fifteen that you don't even have to
think about it you can focus your mental
energy on other things
right cuz you're not intimidated or
worried about facts really great point
other thoughts what makes what really
makes you good at this problem yeah good
yeah
how many of you saw that these problems
that were like yes I'm ready to roll
yeah excellent take a little bit more
into after the problem overall allowed
you to make some progress on this
problem what a lot yeah
good right right
something that you have some kind of uh
you have some overall sense of what your
what the what these symbols mean
physically right you know that two over
three is you know two out of three parts
and you have this governing notion of
what that physical might mean in the
mathematical realm where if I'm gonna do
two over three and five over six those
aren't the same kind of thing and I
can't just straight subtract them across
I good anyone
let's see anyone do this to solve this
one any one x 18 over 18 solve this one
turn it into 12 minus 15 over six plus
four isn't it and we do that one person
why'd you do that
get rid of I'm sure right what what what
so um I am with you on the process what
allows you to see that or those you
didn't see it what what does it what
what doesn't allow you to see it yeah
good right so we're stuck in the we're
stuck in the step by step as opposed to
some kind of uh right some kind of a
vision yeah vision for the end or the
whole right if you know that at some
point we're gonna get rid right you how
many of you when i when i said when i
when i put this problem up could have
told me that the answer is gonna be some
kind of a one number over another number
you all could have done that yes so you
have immediately i still there what the
problem on the board alright and now
we're getting a little bit of the realm
of nervousness as soon as I wrote that
problem the board
you guys knew a few things about what
the answer would look like I've you knew
that it would be something over
something how many of you could have
figured out that the answer was gonna be
negative without doing any calculation
yeah someone tell me why it's gonna be
negative sure sure the tops gonna be
less than zero and the bottoms
definitely many bigger than zero right
if you've got a negative out of a
positive it's gonna be a negative what
about this one what immediately as soon
as I put the problem up did you guys
already know about the answer would you
know it's a freshen some kind of
something between zero and one right
probabilities are always in between zero
and one we knew that immediately if you
got the answer two point eight would you
have been very very upset yeah all of
you would have been right you have this
vision for the end or the hole or what
your answer looks like already
good luck with this one for a second how
did those of you someone who got the
right answer how did you do it
how'd you do it what'd you say
sure good right so there's some element
of counting what else did you guys do
else did we do
okay yeah so you immediately had to make
a creative step right there's not this
one
you can go step by step and pull this
one off this one there's no first step
that lends itself to the answer there's
no okay first I'm going to do this -
this right there has to be some sort of
a creative step there has to be some
sort of a where you say to yourself okay
there's two ways of doing this I could
pull a consonant and a vowel or a vowel
and a consonant and now I have alright
you can even write the way you start
this one is you say ok there's a vowel
consonant probability plus constant
vowel probability and now you can do
whatever the whatever the fractions are
multiply them and add them but what
allows you sewed a little deeper don't
be says have that what allows you to
make that creative move what is it that
allows you to see that a little bit
deeper how does one see that or how
would you take someone who doesn't see
that and get them to see that without
saying here is the answer yeah
sure good right overall sense for what
the physical meaning when we say
probability and also a vision for the
end yeah absolutely
what else what what what makes you able
to do this creative action yeah okay
yeah you've got the you've got the these
knowledge of concepts right you've got
that background information you're
working with a certain set of tools in
your toolbox right so the way you can
say this kind of thing you have tools in
your toolbox like that yeah okay yeah
repetition I think is big this is
similar to some problems that you've
seen in the past sure you're you're able
to recall and compare
I'm gonna press that a little bit so I
think that's a really really good point
okay so making some kind of a decision
and running with it for a while
pretend you make a decision and run with
it for a while okay got a couple
questions a if you're on the right track
how do you know you're on the right
track and B if you're not on the right
track how do you recognize you're not on
the right track and switch things and
now we're really getting into the realm
of number sense here all right you can
see you can have those students in your
mind who can't do one of those things
right who just they pick it to sit
because picking something and running
with it is good right but there's got to
be some checks along the way because you
have the student in your mind right now
who picks something runs with it and
just kind of barrel through and you know
whatever answer shows up is that answer
all right you have that student in mind
all right perfect
next problem I picked it up lit and I
ran with it and just you know okay yeah
so how many of you guys when you
finished look back and said it makes
some sense
all right especially this one right when
you got 10 over 21 how did you check
your answer what you say in your mind
really good right what's the probability
that it's not a constant or or what's
the right way that you get two constant
of the two vowels and make sure that it
adds up to 11 or 21 great what's another
way you could have just checked your
answer okay make sure it goes with the
prediction that we set at the very
beginning what else let me just look at
the letters and say it's about 50%
chance that I'm going to get a consonant
and a vowel right there's about half cos
doesn't have vowels make sense that's
going to be about a half and some kind
of a
ability to check your answer some kind
of an ability to make sure things make
sense all right some kind of a way of
making sure the track you chose was the
right one and if it isn't being able to
pick another track a sudden that's
actually often one of the hardest things
for mathematicians you can think about
it your own son you're in your own math
right when you pick a track and you get
to the end and you realize it shows the
wrong track right this is incorrect you
know it have the ability to go back and
figure out either where you went wrong
or at the track you chose at the very
beginning was different was wrong I
think that's one of the hardest
components of number sense is the
ability to go back and analyze that
point okay so I want to I want to try to
give us this is a really good ideas and
I think we're right I think this is
gonna end up being how I'm gonna define
number sense is by what I'm going less
for kind of this idea it's because
knowledge of concepts I think that's
another kind of an another framework
right that's not really related to the
number sense component I think you
whoever said that is absolutely right
that you need the knowledge of concepts
to be able to pull this off right if you
had never seen the word probability
there's no way you're gonna get that one
right no matter how much number sense
you have right but I think that's the
other realm right that's the conceptual
knowledge realm obviously it's a
conceptual knowledge huh I think number
senses is is more along the lines of
some of these other things so the way
the things when I was thinking about
this myself asking myself what is it
that makes me good at math I kill with
three things and I think these are the
kinds of things that are in those three
things but for me the three things or
one
so this is how I'm gonna define number
sense is one
it's this this component I think is huge
some vision for the end in mind some
ability to before I start a problem have
a vision for what the answer is going to
look like or at least what the answer
should be around or the very least
having some beginning knowledge that
about what even the form that an answer
might take or the you know an estimate
of the answer or and it's it's not
always something right I'm not saying
that I stopped before every problem it
cuz very few of you stopped estimated
and then worked the problem right none
of you did that I'm fairly confident if
you did you're a better person than I am
but you jumped in headlong but I
guarantee you didn't jump in headlong
without some subconscious idea of what
that problem was gonna look like in the
end of what that answer was gonna look
like in the end and that I think is the
number sense component okay you began
with that too
all right
so you can see cut what I'm going here
at there's a beginning the beginning of
the problem there's something that
happens while you're doing the problem
or within the problem and then there's
gonna be something that I do at the very
end right in the middle okay
the number sense component I think is
the abilities is what I'm calling
flexibility or playing around or the
ability to you know it's this idea where
you've got some kind of uh you have the
and I think there's some elements in
here right there is the factual fluency
there is the sort of making a choice and
running with it and not being afraid to
make a choice and run with it and say
I'm gonna try this right there's the
ability to that there's the comfort with
being wrong right all of us are
comfortable with being wrong because we
think okay we learn things from being
wrong and we're able to kind of say okay
well that didn't really work let me try
something else that took forever let's
do it a little bit differently right
this is going to crush my soul let's
find an easier path right and we have
the kind of flex right it has to do with
the conceptual knowledge has to do the
factual fluency has to kind of do with a
little bit with the repetition has to do
with a lot of these things but it's a
it's it's the ability to while you're
solving something do things a little bit
differently change things up look at the
numbers in a little bit of a different
way I'm gonna get some of some of the
examples of what I think this looks like
and we can come back to those and just
sick but I think within the problem it's
the ability to be flexible I think this
is the hardest one to put your finger on
but three I think is pretty easy and I'm
gonna call it so what am I going to call
oh yeah maybe I'm not gonna call that uh
I think should have thought of a better
name then checking your answer let's
call it yeah that's good
some kind of a confirmation step
none of us when we finish if you think
about it if you really think about it
none of us when we get an answer are
done at that point we're not done at
that point when we get the numbers of an
answer and you if you think oh I'm
always done you're not you're checking
it even if you doing it subconsciously
you're comparing it to this you're
compare it and actually almost all of us
if you really think about it when you
get the answer
you don't compare it to the steps that
you did you try to find another way of
comparing it another way of confirming
it say let's think about the problem and
right when you got this negative here
hopefully what you did is you said okay
I don't know if I wasn't so expecting
that let's make sure I should be getting
a negative and you did it a different
way you didn't say well let's make sure
I did all my subtraction steps correctly
you said is my let's look at the problem
as a whole was my answer negative should
mansur be negative you're looking for a
different way all right and maybe yeah
maybe I'm looking for I don't know some
kind of creative confirmation or a
variety of confirmation yeah
right right
so
sure yeah I think actually the the and
the way that I work I don't know if this
is the way that you guys work a lot but
the way that I work is to use a formula
actually as the confirmation of what I
did as opposed to the process by which I
do things I don't know if you too many
of you work like that but I'll often be
doing a math problem and get done with
it
and go back and you know Google a
formula for what I just did and see if
see if it makes sense see if what I did
you know so things like that but I think
there's you know none of us has for any
math problem none of us has one way of
doing it or thinking about it we all are
able to think about it through multiple
pathways I'd do the same answer and we
use those multiple pathways to say oh
yeah this lines up perfectly right and
they're right there's two different
scenarios and in an and formula or I
guess it's an or formula right there's
two different components of that formula
right well that's beautiful that's
beautiful that's beautiful and you're
getting a little bit with that component
which I think it's nice but for me this
is what I'm defining as number sensing
I've said this to a few of you I know
already but I think if we really think
about it this is what makes us good at
what we do and so all right the big
question being how does one instill this
right so the big question right yeah
okay so I'm running with this definition
number sense right big question right
how does one develop this in one's
students right how does one get someone
who doesn't do this to be able to do
this right good
I'm gonna work yes yeah that's a good
point
yeah I think that's it she said the
reason why a lot of times we're
comfortably well being wrong is that
we're often right and so it's sort of a
rarity and that's not necessarily the
case for most of our students I think
it's a really good point I think the
other reason why we're comfortable being
wrong is we know that when we are wrong
we're able to pull ourselves out of that
most of the time right very few times in
your lives probably have you been truly
and utterly stumped by a math problem
compared the subset of that to the
subset of math problems you've done in
your life right the fraction is
miniscule right it's close to zero yes
it's close to zero number sense
I'm gonna take these one by one I take
these one by one and try to give us both
some things you can do so what I want to
try to do specifically is I think
there's a couple different ways you can
access each one of these things there
are I think some specific things you can
do in your classroom that are directly
targeting one of these three things
there's also some things you can
incorporate into your daily teaching
habits that are so I think in each one
of these there's going to be a right
there's gonna be a direct way to address
these things in an indirect way to
Russia and what I mean by that is just
you know I don't know pretend I think
mr. Wagner needs a haircut right there's
a direct way I can address that
go get a haircut right or I could do
very indirect ways of addressing that
right and it's sometimes the indirect
ways are actually more effective in the
direct ways right there's some very
indirect ways I can tell him to get a
haircut right I can compliment mr.
Boucher on his hair I can you know you
know reach over and like pluck one of
the like stray hairs that he's got going
on you know I can I can yes oh no they
were not appropriate ways of doing this
but often the in often the indirect ways
are more effective I think that's true
in teaching as well right often the
things that we do directly to address
something are good but the things that
we incorporate into our daily teaching
habits are actually the things that make
more of a difference right I think I
found that to be true probably all of
you do as well so I'm gonna try to give
us some direct things we can practically
do in some ways that maybe we
incorporate into our teaching habits I
think as far as the three of these these
two are relatively compared with this
one these two are relatively easy or at
least relatively easy to start working
with your students on so let's take
those first one so let's see let's do
one vision some kind of a vision
biggest practical or biggest let's do
the let's do the indirect first right
best way of doing this is simply to make
it a part of every problem make it a
part of every problem you can begin
so indirect just begin just begin every
problem by making predictions it's a
easy easy way of starting to get your
kids thinking about this and before you
a lot of us jump directly into couch
guess here's the thing none of you began
this yourself by making predictions and
you just jump right in but that's not
exactly true you had a prediction in the
back of your mind as entire time that's
what we said right we had a vision for
the end all along right so if you what
we tend to do as mathematicians is jump
right into the solving process assuming
that everyone has the same vision in or
at least assuming that there is this
vision that's going on in students heads
and that's not true the students don't
have that so you need to say in your
mind what is it about this problem that
I implicitly understand and make those
questions real in front of your students
right so asking this right asking
yourself
I asked ask yourself what do I
implicitly understand and those are the
questions that you want to ask your
students those are the things you want
to make a reality okay
good questions include I wrote some
things down
my aunt's are gonna be close to they're
gonna be bigger or less than zero is it
gonna be bigger less than one it's gonna
be bigger less than a hundred we were
less than a million what is no even
think of a simple problem what is 843
how big is it it's it close to what is
194 how big is it is it close to what is
our answer gonna be close to what is
edition what does it mean to add these
are things that you don't even think
about I don't even think about give a
guess for our answer why is it a good
guess is there a better guess can we do
list the everyone write down a guess on
your paper let's list them up here ask
why did you guess that why'd you guess
that why is it gonna be bigger it's all
these Y kinds of questions without even
starting into the calculation right tell
your students put their pencils down
hands in the air look at me let's before
we even do the problem let's figure out
some things that we can predict about
what its gonna look like
don't let them start jumping into
calculation or don't assume that they
can write this one right it's a
numerator gonna be greater or less than
zero they're not denominator to be
greater less than zero is the answer
gonna be the numerator gonna be great
less than one it's very difficult to get
your kids to be able to estimate the
answer to a problem like this but if you
were gonna estimate it just ask yourself
how would I do it
what am I employ what do I know in the
back of my mind and ask your students
those questions to start your lesson
start your problem have them make
predictions about what's going on before
they even start the only way for them to
ever internalize that and make that up
they get something that they don't have
to think about is to start by thinking
about it
the only way you have bitchu ate
something is you have to actually do it
for a while if to think about doing it
before you unconsciously do it the way
you learned to brush your teeth at the
end of the night most of you hopefully
is your parents made you brush your
teeth every day until now none of you
think about it as part of your daily
routine you have to be intentional about
not jumping into the solving step before
you're doing the gaining division step
yeah yeah okay
so let's throw it let's throw a calculus
problem up here right you're standing at
the edge of a river you need to make it
back to your campsite all right you can
swim let's see this distance is three
miles big river that distance is four
miles you can swim at one mile an hour
and you can walk at two miles an hour
all right calculus problem what are some
questions you could ask beforehand about
this calculus problem without starting
it no calculation required okay yeah
[Laughter]
precisely browser says assume the river
is not moving
what are some questions is a difficult
exercise think about it though
what are something you could ask your
students about this okay yeah what's
your answer going to even just what is
the answer gonna look like answers gonna
be a time and some kind of a distance
that you want to hit that opposite shore
some kind of a spot that you want to
write and now you're getting into where
your variable goes what else could you
ask what shape is the tenth that might
be a good way to hook them in but
probably not entirely appropriate yes be
the car no good right
what's the direct distance think about
you guys are doing a little bit more
you're already jumping into the solving
stage you guys are done you guys are
jumping into thee you know let's
calculate square root and this is gonna
be five right you guys are you're
jumping ahead I'm saying before that
what questions can you ask even before
even before questions can you ask okay
something like that right what's a
longer distance do we want to swim
longer or do we want to walk longer why
why shouldn't we just swim directly
yeah even getting them to make a
prediction about the answer is it gonna
take me longer or shorter than an hour
longer right but now now you follow it
up with why okay why is it gonna take
you longer and now that student who
answered longer has to go and articulate
why it's going to be longer and if it's
going to be longer because at the very
least I have to swim three direct miles
and I can only swim at one mile an hour
so my answers gonna have to be
that's just bigger than one but some
kind of bigger than three what's my
answer going to be less than or what's
the absolute maximum my answer could be
five and why are you saying that you
could swim directly there and it would
take you five hours so now guess what
I've done before any calculations have
happened I've taken a complex ocular
calculus problem right you have to use
the chain rule to solve this problem you
have to get you've to take the square
root of three to solve this problem
right what you think it's great for you
solves problem all right we'll do it and
we'll take the square root of three I
guarantee I'll take a skirt of three you
have to do both those things dollars but
I've already done this I know my answer
within two hours which is run out that
short of a time but it's at least you
know all you eliminated at this point
all the answers that you might get that
are 13 hours or 21 minutes I could do it
you've eliminated those things already
with a few simple questions beforehand
right often times we jump right into the
calculation step stop before you do a
problem doesn't matter if it's calculus
problem or an algebra problem or a
second-grade problem you can ask the
same kinds of questions before you start
there's a long ways don't your students
jump into calculation without getting a
vision for what's going on the best way
of so then are you kind of direct or
saria I guess maybe that's less indirect
but one way of doing it okay incorporate
that into your teaching habits make it
not something that you jump into and
it's the easiest set of questions to ask
once you get in the habit of it because
you can just do it every time you just
say what's a good guess for this answer
right if they say oh no which a lot of
students will look at this problem
you're like I have no idea you hook them
in by saying is it bigger than one why
is it less than ten less than a million
why they'll be like well we know that if
this is true it's an obvious thing that
it starts to be less obvious it starts
to be able to a ballpark even ballpark
an answer indirect way of doing direct
way of doing it the best way to do this
activity all right my directors an
activity specifically designed to
address this it's challenging them to do
mental calculation okay I don't mean
mental calculation of problems like 138
plus 412 although that would be good
I mean mental calculation of some of the
problems that you're gonna see in the
upper school I mean these problems I'll
give you guys a few all right here I'll
see some the ones I did some ones I
thought okay we just give you four
examples
30 seconds who can get this one no
writing mrs. haffen on mental
calculation who can get it 30 seconds
mr. Wagner what you got no idea anyone
everyone think they've got answer all
right
Oh mrs. Reagan plus actually I'm
doubting myself someone type it into a
computer gotta end it - how about this
think about I'm all seducing the answer
so much as what happened when you were
doing that what happened your mind what
did you do
okay you broke it up into pieces right
yes you broke it up into some pieces you
you all right and you also gained
yourself a little bit of vision for the
mind it for the end in mind right you
said you got an order of magnitude that
you expected the answer to be in right
you knew is gonna be in the ten
thousands ish right somewhere in that
order of magnitude though right you also
knew that it was gonna end there too
right
it's kind of things right the more you
practice mental calculation the better
okay let's give a couple other ones here
about this one no calculations sign of
37 degrees a little more than a half
sure yeah
a little more than a half somewhere
right around probably point five I
didn't write the answer down to these I
just coming up right but again what do
you do with that problem you knew
something some of you might have thought
about a triangle maybe or at least
something on the unit circle right some
of you thought about the graph all right
where's 37 degrees all right and again
if you think about not letting your
students type sine of 37
their calculators all the time you let
them type sine 37 in you calculated
because you know you can't calculate it
otherwise but before they're able to do
that have them stop and make a
prediction give them a few even this is
a great way to start your day
one problem just one that they have to
think about in their heads and give
yourself a guess best guess tonight off
of homework no but best gets gets you
know whatever you want right something
something like you know no it's pretty
ninety one cube root a ninety one and
most your students are gonna be able to
say it's between nine and ten but force
them to go a little bit right actually
get the closest guess that they can get
all right maybe have them do think about
oh maybe some of you guys are doing nine
point five times nine point five in your
heads maybe none of you are doing that
whatever right mental calculation have
some form of it in your class at some
point right this is not a calculus thing
there's not a algebra thing this is just
the best way to specifically target that
vision some kind of mental calculation
don't let him tell you everything in the
calculator I mean do let him type stuff
in the gutter but don't make them make
predictions
natural bugger 19 really funny anyway so
you guys get the idea
shoulda brought a calculator to actually
give some answers should have played
that game right here we should had a
little challenge
I've been fun I'm regretting not that I
don't regret not doing that alright
anyways questions about some ways to do
and yet or any other ideas about some
ways to do waste I really get at number
one here in there ways that you guys are
thinking about a lot of one is gonna be
connected to two and actually also three
your calculator
all right everyone make a guess of the
natural log of 19 everyone make a guess
uh oh look it's right over here we make
it guess anyone willing to share their
guess 2.6 that's a stark 3.2 who is that
climbin your mind who's that 3 doubtful
but anyone else any other one natural
log of 19 one more one all right well we
got this right here nice mr. f poor
victorious nice you win the you win
right ok but something like that alright
is nothing and now what you--what would
you follow up that question what
question would you follow up the
exercise with why yeah how'd you do it
what do you think about what were you
thinking about and talk about it right
your kids are gonna be really bad at
this at the beginning gonna be really
bad and the only way for them to get
better is for you to give them a shot at
it talk about why you why things are the
way they have do it it's fun it wasn't
one of fun parts of teaching you to make
fun of people who say answers like 11.8
for natural log in nineteen
yes oh I usually just have him write it
down and then you know sometimes I'll
throw them up on the board but everyone
gets to write something down in circle
it just so that they know I you know
sometimes your kids have no idea what's
going on we could guess and they'll win
and then you'll have to ask them why and
they'll be like I have no idea and then
you'll say no no no you said wrote that
for a reason why did you write that
actually you know these kind of things I
don't really take the time to put
everything on the board necessarily
sometimes it makes more sense to put
some put some things on the board but
doesn't need to be a long part and
actually you have to be at the beginning
right well if you've got some
calculation during your lesson is better
if you can circle that in your lesson
plans and be like alright when we get
here everyone's gonna give it a guess
it's a better way to do it i corps
parade it actually into the lesson
everyone makes a prediction for this one
you can also do it in your homework all
right
short question on the on a worksheet
says make prediction for this say Y
really good thing to put on a homework
assignment just at the beginning overdue
stock flexibility it's a tough one I
shouldn't grace that we're gonna do that
problem and see how we have to take the
square root of three flexibility
I just call playing around some thoughts
about how to do this let's do some
direct stood erect first there are some
gay math games you can play that
directly make them play around with
numbers there's no way you can play the
game without being able to do this
just a couple that I'll mention not
necessarily games but let's just do ways
I've got two things in here so there's
games something else so things like off
you get some of you guys this tell me
guys crypto if taught few of you math
dice which is fun up
I guess I'll teach you just these real
briefly no I won't hmm yeah well yeah
cuz they're fine crypto just something
like give them five numbers and then a
fifth number or a sixth number you got
them rearrange the first five and make
them equal the sixth one something like
this oh my god
sorts of solutions to these guaranteed
have to mess around with numbers they
have to try a bunch of different facts
you don't play with five numbers if you
teach in six or seventh graders you want
to play with four numbers three numbers
even
they have to mess with facts they have
to try stuff they have to think about
different ways of doing things you're
really high students you can ask him for
three or four solutions all right
Arlo students even if they don't get
enter getting solution they've tried
seven or eight different things they've
had to play around with the numbers most
of the things you try are going to be
wrong right this ability to be wrong
it's comfort with being wrong because
there's other things to try other things
too dry mouth dice is pretty easy I'll
roll I can roll whatever you want I like
to roll to 20-sided die and for either
six-sided or ten sided die so pretend I
got 19 and 6 and then two three six and
six multiply the first two yeah play
with you play with only three of these
you can play with whatever you want
right well the first two is where that
114 one in 14 14 14 all right try to get
those four - any combinations to get as
close as possible to 114 all right what
they what you do is when you get
something they can call it out so for
instance the first thing I might say
might be I don't know I could hear
someone say 41 as you're trying things
as you're trying things you're calling
out your answers that you're getting and
then someone someone could get closer
right I don't know someone say 42 or or
you know 100 n 3 so I'm saying I could
say 41 if I'm thinking no 6 times 6 plus
3 plus 2 all right I can say 42 if I'm
thinking 2 times 3 times 6 plus 6 I
could say
seventy-five I'm thinking six times six
times two plus three I mean if you can
get okay I'm gonna get closer someone
call it a number yeah
call it out just call it the number just
call what you got 110 you use exponents
if you want
just like Steen lady I can get 120 I
think yeah nice there's a score how'd
you do it six times six times three plus
two good
so you'd win that round but you're
getting kids to call out whatever
answers they're getting right and so
that they're just playing her out the
numbers and trying to figure out
something that's a little bit better
player outfit and the best person who
wins gets a point you don't have to get
them from crypto or that you don't to
get an exact solution you can play with
around with it and try to get as close
as possible roll again you play again so
something like this if you got an extra
five or ten minutes in your classroom if
you've got something kids love doing
these kind of game type things
easy to do you just roll in and asking
them for solutions but something that's
directly designed to get them to play
with numbers they don't play with
numbers enough my mom always says the
reason why I'm good at math is when I
was two she played endless endless
endless games of war with me and that's
probably true the reason why I'm good at
math just because there's intentional
and nothing war is playing with numbers
but some kind of associating this you
know we would invent new games all these
kinds of things get creative about
finding ways specifically for kids to
play with numbers if you really want
some rules to either of those games I
think I've got some rule sheets
somewhere you can have the other way of
doing this right I've seen this happen
actually I watched your happen really
well at mr. Beach's class right
some kind of a non curricular problem
with with no real exact solution found
really effective for instance I actually
got a text from a friend the other day
said all right I'm at this concert and
he drew me a little picture said I'm at
this concert here's the stage and it
looks something like this
and there's a line of porta-potties
along the back giving a random place in
the concert it's the probability that I
should go into the center and then back
out one of the radial lines versus going
out and around there's no exact solution
to this and this didn't give me enough
information to do it but I spent about
an hour and a half on it and came up
with something relatively creative all
right interesting problem right and
actually there's a couple of fun
there's a couple there was a couple
really fun things about the units of
that problem some of the variables that
I assigned to various things that then
were related like you know that were
ended up being able to relate to one
another in cool ways but something like
that designed you know you don't want to
do this every day necessarily but every
once in a while bring in something like
that designed to just play around with
it there's no exact solution but all
we're doing is playing all we're doing
with messing around we have to make some
assumptions we have to write some
equations we have to know a few concepts
I have to know some things about circles
and how the radius is related to
circumference but really all I'm doing
is playing with the students I'm messing
around getting them to think about
something in a little bit of a not
following the formula way but having to
make that creative move having to make
that starting point having to start
thinking about what things
matter and what things don't matter and
how much do they matter actually the
radius of that problem matters not at
all doesn't matter no matter how big
your circle is really cool all right
find some ways to incorporate specific
ways where you're not looking for
anything except for them to play except
for them to try something some of the
indirect ways are more important I think
in this in this scenario a couple
thoughts let them play in order to
generate the formulas let them play
before you generate formulas for
instance a problem like this before you
taught a linear combination or
substitution throw the problem up there
and let them mess around with it for a
while maybe you might get some answers
all right let him mess with it given you
know have someone say what's the answer
gonna be you know three and eight all
right why do you three name that work
what would we have to change it
look at make Y bigger we can make X
bigger why doesn't it work to make Y
bigger well then you got to deal with
that second problem but actually what's
gonna happen here I just they're gonna
play with it what actually happens is
that at the end of that playing you end
up with the idea that what we need is a
way to take both of those equations and
work with them at the same time without
losing the information in either one
and guess what substitution and linear
combination are that's what they are
right there a way of using both
equations at the same time without
losing the information in either one the
way they get that is to say is to play
other for I'll and say man will be
really helpful if we had this and now
you're like boom formula or boom process
of doing this because that's how
got invented someone was messing around
with it and say I know how to do this I
can do this every single time and let
the kids play before you give him the
process but I'm play with it for a while
call it answers haven't called answers
be comfortable with the wrong thing
because every time you say that's a
great idea let's check let's check it
out oh it doesn't quite work okay well
how can we change it it's kind of things
really really fun things and guys can't
emphasize this enough that is what's fun
about teaching no one wakes up in the
morning and says I'm really excited to
make sure my kids have the quadratic
formula down in their notes today just
don't do that I'm really excited to have
them play around with quadratics until
we figure something out together that's
what I said okay I'm sorry next and
related related to this thing like
pursue wrong avenues of thought in your
classroom pursue wrong avenues of
thought when you get an answer that's
incorrect take it and run with it until
it becomes really apparent that it's
incorrect and don't do that in a way
that say that's you know the student
gave that answer is gonna be
uncomfortable but do it anyway encourage
that answer say that's a really good
idea and then at the end come back and
say well okay we saw what's wrong but
why did you say that there's a really
good idea in there something like I
don't know a couple different examples I
thought of here
throw that from the board after you've
taught factoring but before you've
taught the quadratic formula or
completing the square they're always
gonna write I'm specifically seeking out
wrong avenues of thought here right
I'm they don't have the right Avenue of
thought I'm specifically making them
give me wrong answers in order to get
the in order to a get the idea of what
it means to play around with a quadratic
and what it might mean to solve
something like that and why factoring
doesn't work but also to generate a
culture in my classroom where being
wrong is okay just because not being
wrong is okay in that wrong answers
right answers we don't care about it but
being wrong is part of the way we get to
the right answer I love doing something
like I don't know if you're doing
calculus right throw something like this
it's a partial fraction decomposition
problem and only solve it by partial
fraction decomposition but I guarantee
you students will try your substitution
I guarantee they'll try integration by
parts don't play around with it for a
while and they'll come to realize that
it can't be integration by parts because
it's so close to be integration by parts
are so close to being a new substitution
problem it's neither of those two things
it's so close and they're playing with
it they're coming to the realization
that I need something new I need
something new you're okay being wrong
because you someone says we can do u
substitution here great let's do it you
equals what oh you equals x squared
minus 2x minus 3 that sounds right
all right 2x minus 2 let's make our
substitution and run with it
take it and go wrong with it you don't
need to shut down wrong answers
never they're given don't shut them down
they are wrong take him and go with him
that culture of your classroom is will
change overnight not overnight over a
long period of time
well on create a very difficult time
yeah do that yeah the you mean just you
mean saying something like sorry glad
sure
it's exactly right yeah say okay we came
to a logical inconsistency therefore our
step at the very beginning can't be
right look
is there another step we can do yeah
it's the RA a kind of a kind of a proof
all right rid reductio ad absurdum so
like protect you got it I'm doing that
right is that right
ra yeah so you make an assumption take
it to something that you know is gonna
be false therefore your assumption
it's called RA a proof or or indirect
proof yeah yeah a lot of some
mathematicians think RA a proofs are
completely wrong they only like direct
proof I'm a big fan all right it's a
couple of the things I was thinking
about it here all right discuss
strategies and explanations all right I
love doing this with my students I call
it a 30 second explanation I told you
guys told somebody this right
but ask him for a 30 second second
explanation of a problem right or let's
try one I'll see so Wagner 30 second
explanation of a parabola go
done nice well done good round of
applause Ron Paul's round applause wrap
up someone else thirty seconds of an
explanation of this problem right here
Tomek go solve it whole problem 30
seconds I'm good good
what am i doing when I'm doing that what
what what did he have to do to give that
they ever do go know the process in his
mind right distilling the important
things from the unimportant things if
you have 30 seconds to explain it you
can't say something like first I made a
comment I'm sure you guys do his all
time when he asked his students to
explain a problem so two over three
ahead multiply both the numerator and
the denominator by two or just gives me
4 over 6 and 1 over 3 I to multiply the
numeron it's just baggage your class
down right 30 secs planation like now
you're on the clock
right you have to distill the important
things from the non important things
that inhibit the essential kind of
things say so I noticed that all my
denominators had a common denominator of
18 so I multiply the top and the bottom
by 18 I can do that because 18 or 18 is
1 I could multiply anything I want by
wanna 18 cancels out all my denominators
leaves me with several things in the
numerators subtracted and add and I was
good to go like that 30 second equation
you have to coach your students and I do
that they're not gonna do that right
away but give them the chance and then
say who can give me a better 30 is like
an explanation of that problem who can
give me these kind of things getting
them the chance to distill the important
parts of what happened in the middle
from the unimportant parts really good
talk strategies with them related right
celebrate different
celebrate different ways to get an
answer celebrate that every system of
equations celebrate both substitution
and linear combination who have one of
your students who's like a substitution
guy he's gonna do sub solution every
single time and like my substitution guy
right how the substitution work on that
problem all right you know there's a
couple kids who really just love
substitution and hate linear combination
and there's other students who really
love leading operation and some problems
right it's so hard
new linear combination with and it's or
other problems it's almost impossible
new substitution you get so money
fractions and gross things right and so
you you you celebrate both the different
ways you take those papers you throw one
of the document camera you say look what
this guy did
that's so cool your kids are gonna start
being the ones who want to have their
papers under the document camera because
oh that was gold that was different I
did a different way I thought about it
this way I thought about this way
I thought about this way he's always
really good celebrate those kind of
things
it's a little bit more up here maybe you
haven't played around with some extra
credit questions on the just not an exam
I'm talking about not curricular extra
credit questions but just questions
designed to have the kids mess around
with them for a while like I know things
some of the classic math puzzles if you
guys are going to the math puzzles one
you probably get some good ideas for
some good extra credit questions
something like this draw four lines
straight lines that are connected that
hit each one of those nine points all
right some of you guys have probably
seen this before so you guys maybe
haven't in which case it's a fun one
it's a really fun one it's very
difficult how you think okay four lines
one two three four missed one solutions
pretty fun I won't I'll let that I'll
let that simmer so that some of you guys
can work on it for for awhile it's a fun
walk but things like even just stuff
like I don't know fill in six circles so
that there are an even number of circles
in each row and column stuff like this
right I'm throwing it give half a point
on your test for it
so that it doesn't really affect the
grade but let your kids play around with
stuff for a while
what a mess with stuff actually matters
in terms of number senses this kind of
stuff mathematics is six circles even
number in each row and column go for it
how many squares are there on a chess
board
how many squares are there in a chess
board there's 64 1 by 1 squares throw it
at the end of your test and see what
happens right make them play around with
it for a while yeah right mess with them
cool let's do the last one just I think
we got what do we have 5 minutes my gosh
I'm not gonna nearly get to what I want
to get to it's ok 3 suit conformation
for just a sec again I think this is an
easier one especially with this indirect
portion the habits of teaching habits of
teaching just like at the beginning of
every problem by making a prediction and
every problem by asking whether it makes
sense asking why it makes sense asking
how it compares to your prediction right
is it different why is it different why
is that answer different than we expect
should that cause us to go and relook at
what we did is it different enough that
we had a was our prediction right and
our answer run or as our answer right
and our prediction was off why those
kind of questions right the you know I
was gonna do that calculus problem and
you know get our answer and say just
have you asked that that even give me
the SoCalGas question why does that
answer make sense well makes sense that
we would hit the shore pretty quickly
because we can run twice as fast as we
can swim all right
makes sense that we'd hit that shore
pretty quickly right or you know makes
sense that the time is about three point
eight nine hours ish I don't know today
when don't end up doing that one well
I've been talking no one that's good for
me hey you guys are not bored oh did
what'd you get for the time it takes
oh yeah what's the distance is it square
root 3 nice 3 over root 15 it's a pretty
pretty smaller number from directly blah
yeah the but asking you right so
indirectly right and and every problem
and every problem by asking whether or
not your answer makes sense and again
right why compare it to the beginning
again this is something that as
mathematicians we do subconsciously we
end every problem and like we said the
very beginning we do this without
thinking about it but our students don't
do that and so we need to make that
explicit so that they do think about it
until it becomes habit and it's the
easiest thing to incorporate into your
teaching if you want looking for some
number sense ideas start every part with
a prediction and every problem with a
asking why it makes sense easiest thing
to start incorporating it doesn't take
any extra work on your part
doesn't take anything fancy but it gets
the kids asking the right kinds of
questions easy
may be the indirect or the direct ways
of doing this I do this directly on
homework actually which sounds I don't
know if I have time to go into my entire
homework policy here but what I do is
the the thing that I look for on my
homework
is for students not to get answers so
much as to make observations about their
problems I have been known and I tell my
students this to give tens on homework
that has no right answers which I is
again I know is not very like you don't
want to get in the habit of doing that
necessarily but if a student said
something got stuck on a problem
whatever may be your calculus problem
they got stuck and they said I got stuck
here this is what I and you know they're
writing this I'm the problem I'm the
problem in their homework I got stuck
here I tried this I got stuck there I
tried this thing I stuck there I don't
know what to do but here's what I tried
and here's why it was wrong and they
write that on their problem I will give
that a 10 out of 10 every time and they
know that
let me get stuck they know now I won't
get I won't give that right you can't
give that right on the test right
can't get that right on the quiz
something like that you don't get points
for that but on a homework assignment
when I just I'm looking for them to
communicate with me and looking for them
to say I'll ask questions on homework
and say why does this make sense and if
you can't get the right answer but not
tell me why it makes sense you're
definitely not gonna give full points on
it if you're correcting your homework
and you put if they put a they say I got
this one wrong I got this one and they
right next to it while they're
correcting him I got some wrong
professor Greg but I know exactly why
aren't wrong I went wrong right here all
right I'm not gonna do that again these
kind of things on my homework I directly
make them encourage them just stop and
think about their problems and stop and
think about right you know to say put a
little thing like this after problem
wanting problem two and say something
like this is different because right
iein sent if I - is different than one
because of this find ways to incentivize
them to make those kind of observations
I do it by specifically crafting my
homework and my homework policies in
order to encourage that
you may do it a different way I'm just
trying to get the students in the habit
of not just rushing through the
calculation figuring out a way to stop
confirm and review what they're doing
stopping and confirming and reviewing
what they're doing saying like I get to
the end of a problem I know this is
wrong because the answer is too big I
know I did this right I know I did this
right but I didn't I know something's
wrong
not really sure but it's got to be in
one of these couple steps it smell like
that written at the end of a homework
assignment that shows me not meet your
understanding or true factual or true
fluency with the process but it shows me
as a teacher that they are thinking
about the problem and not just using it
as another thing too we really want to
do is we want to generate thought when I
generate confidence and habits of doing
some of these kind of things do number
sense it's not easy your students will
be bad at literally all of these things
the first several times that you do them
the first year that you do them the
first months that you do them it'll be
bad at all of them because they haven't
been trained in any of these things
they're so worth trying to start doing
in your classroom and start thinking
about some other ways you do it if you
have other thoughts about these I was
hoping to leave like for an hour for
other thoughts about this obviously that
didn't happen I'd love to hear some of
your other thoughts but not now because
you guys are tired of hearing me talk
and want to go grab some coffee thank
you all
[Applause]